вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі з вами я ліс шу Ми
почнемо сьогоднішню програму зі Швеції
де Влада намагається взяти під контроль
дедалі більшу проблему бандитського
насильства організована злочинність
зачіпає дедалі більше людей у Швеції
омеру саріхану наприклад довелося
пережити гірку втрату у своїй родині
тепер він хоче щоб влада робила більше
для захисту громадян від злочинців
шведські соціальні працівники також
відігра важливу роль у профілактичній
роботі але це перегони з часом рівень
збройного насильства зростає особливо
серед молоді у годсунда передмісті
упсали соціальні працівники намагаються
дістатися до молодих людей до того як їх
заманять неправдивими обіцянками члени
банд і вони стануть на небезпечний а
іноді і Смертельний
шлях омеру серіхану досі важко ходити на
кладовище майже 50 років тому він виїха
із Туреччини до Швеції думаючи що це
Мирна
країна Сьогодні він стоїть на могилі
свого сина сердара якого застрелили
бандити саріхан досі не може у це
повірити на могильній плиці написані
слова Ми дуже за тобою
сумуємо мій син був для мене не просто
сином він був моїм найкращим другом і
компаньйоном він був для мене всім
працювита людина з
принципами він був агентом із
нерухомості якого застрелили на очах у
дружини і дітей у власному будинку
поблизу Стокгольма імовірно Це був акт
помсти син сердара онук омера імовірно
був пов'язаний із бандою і його
підозрюють у тому що він стріляв по
будинку сім'ї члена конкуруючої банди
фотографію мо Онука показали по
телебаченню заголовком
розшукується через три години мій син
був
мертвим імовірна причетність його Онука
до бандитських угрупувань лежить важким
тягарем на плечах омера він і його сім'я
вже багато років не спілкуються із
онуком ми доклали багато зусиль щоб він
міг знайти роботу і жити нормальним
життям Але на жаль він обрав такий
шлях
війни між бандитами роками сіяли страх і
терор у Швеції у 2022 році вони забрали
62 життя більше ніж будь-коли раніше за
підрахунками улстіт jжourнаal в одному
лише Стокгольмі рівень вбивства на душу
населення у 30 разів вище ніж у Лондоні
конфлікти в основному розгортаються
навколо боротьби за територію у
наркоторгівлі іноді ідеться просто про
захист так званої честі більшість
злочинців походять із мігрантських
спільнот
[музика]
вони стріляють через двері квартир і по
автомобілях кидаючи ручні гранати і
підкладають бомби у результаті гине
дедалі більше невинних
людей уряд Швеції у стані підвищеної
готовності Швеція ніколи не переживала
нічого подібного жодна країна у Європі
не переживала нічого подібного Я
попросив шефа національної поліції і
командувача армії приєднатися до мене ми
хочемо бачити як армія допомагає поліції
у боротьбі зі злочинними
угрупованнями на вулицях Стокгольма
немає жодного солдата який би патрулював
їх поки що але для
журналіста-розслідувача діаманта саліху
ця заява уряду свідчить про те наскільки
потужними стали злочинні угрупування у
Швеції на даний момент існує один
великий конфлікт всередині мережі під
назвою мережа Фокстрот яка розділилася
на дві фракції через борги через
внутрішні
конфлікти і зараз вони воюють одна із
одною на
смерть велика проблема з якою стикається
шведська влада у вирішенні цієї ситуації
полягає у тому що лідери які контролюють
більшу частину наркоринку діють із-за
кордону поліція годсунда передміся
центрального шведського міста упсала
визнала Цей район зоною підвищеного
ризику згідно із повідомленнями
шведських ЗМІ банди полюбляють вербувати
тут нових членів
нодьгани повага до правоохоронних
органів і м'які вироки усе це полегшує
бандам їхню
[музика]
роботу Цей район забудований соціальним
житлом зведеним у
1960х і 70-х роках сьогодні Більшість
населення тут складають імігра
більшість із 10 я домогосподарства тут
вважаються
[музика]
малозабезпеченими 15тирічний Ахмед веде
нас на екскурсію районом госунда Він
народився в Іраку і приїхав до Швеції із
батьками 10 років
тому у людей так багато упереджень щодо
гоцунда то тут живе як одна
сім'я ми всі добре ладнаємо між
собою після школи Ахмет гуляє на вулиці
зі своїм другом абедом Іноді вони ходять
до одного із двох молодіжних клубів
госунда які працюють цілий день ніхто
тут не хоче щоб їх знімали Ахмет каже що
в окрузі є багато розваг але багато
дітей його віку усе одно стають на
Злочинний
шлях
Так у мене є багато друзів які
займаються такими
речами але я завжди намагаюся триматися
подалі від
цього завжди є ризик бути втягнутиму
щось
подібне я намагаюся не гуляти до пізна і
стараюся бути в компанії
друзів така обережність ахмеда
виправдана у серпні автобусі у годсунді
підстрелили 13тирічного хлопчика він
ходить до школи
ахмеда де далі молодшими стають не лише
жертви а й злочинці лідери банд
переважно вербують
14-15тирічних підлітків яким зазвичай
платять за перші доручення суму
еквівалентну кільком сотням євро пізніше
ї можуть замовити вбивство за яке
платять набагато
більше де далі молодший вік новобранців
свід про повну неспроможність держави і
суспільства у Швеції вважає експерт
діамант саліху він також дитина
імігрантів із
Косово у Швеції за вбивство якщо тобі 16
років ти можеш отримати максимум 4отири
роки у колонії для неповнолітніх де ти
можеш мати доступ до айпаду і
спілкуватися з друзями на волі тобто
ризик дуже низький порівняно з
винагородою яку вони можуть отримати
грошима або що досить часто трапляється
статусом ці троє соціальних працівників
у годсунді виходять на вулиці щоб
запобігти потраплянню неповнолітніх до
лап
банд щовечора о 18 годині вони ідуть до
торгового центру і розмовляють із
охоронцями І що важливіше із молодими
людьми їхнє послання просте митут для
всіх хто потребує допомоги але іноді
банди виявляються швидшими
так Вони намагаються вербувати молодь
але ми ідемо у середні школи у четвертій
і п'ятій класи Коли їм приблизно по
10-11
років і намагаємося розповісти їм про
тривожні знаки про те що може
трапитись а також про те що законно А що
ні яку підтримку можна
отримати звісно Ми не можемо дати їм те
що можуть дати вербувальники але ми
намагаємося запропонувати їм роботу
змістовне дозвілля позитивні приклади
для наслідування і таке інше На жаль
вони здебільшого живуть одним днем або
годиною і думають О Можливо я зможу
отримати якийсь статус Можливо я зможу
отримати Швидкі гроші вони не бачать чим
це обернеться у довгостроковій
перспективі і саме про це ми намагаємося
із ними говорити згідно зі звітом
поліції за 2022 рік лише одну із
чотирьох стрілянин зі смертельними
наслідками в ється
розкрити поліцейське управління у
годсунді вважає критику на свою адресу
необґрунтованою оскільки Їхня робота
обмежується
законом існує закон від 1942го року який
забороняє нам обшукувати будинки після
9ти вечора якщо немає виняткових
обставин у наш час злочинці просто не
встають до 9ї
вечора зараз нас турбує те що так багато
невинних людей стають жертвами цих
конфліктів Хоча вони не мають до них
жодного
стосунку Ахмед і його друг абед не
бачить для себе майбутнього із бандами
готсунди натомість їх зацікавила Нова
студія звукозапису в молодіжному
центрі діти та молоді з району вже
створили хід під назвою ми
госунда
[музика]
[оплески]
це те на чому ми повинні зосередитися
щоб у всіх все було добре щоб всі
почувалися у безпеці і
вдома протягом багатьох років омеррі
також відчував себе вдома у
Швеції Але після насильницької смерті
сина його почуття змінилися і він каже
що в цьому багато
винних та баш
сучлам перш за все це вина наркобаронів
які замовили
вбивство і злочинців які його
здійснили третій винуватець мій онук
який втягнув нас у цю
ситуацію і зрештою влада яка так довго
спостерігала за цим коли мала б захищати
своїх
громадян Омер саріхан не єдиний Хто хоче
знову відчути себе в безпеці у
[музика]
Швеції
Я впевнена що в кожної країни світу є та
страва яка або викликає людей цікавість
або змушує їх недовірливо хитати головою
для Франції така особлива страва жаби
жаб'ячі лапки зокрема століттями
вважалися делікатесом але місцевих жаб
стає дедалі важче знайти оскільки
французька Влада майже повністю
заборонила комерційне полювання на жаб
однак селекціонер Патріс Франсуа Хоче
змінити ситуацію тому він пропонує
їстівних жаб вирощених у Франції і це
саме те що потрібно шеф-кухарю одного
висококласного ресторану у колонж
омондор щоб вразити Своїх
гостей Греція один із провідних світових
виробників оливкової олії але на острові
Крит сильна спека і посуха призвели до
різкого скорочення
врожаю за останні кілька років Ціна на
оливкову олію суттєво зросла оливки
стали настільки цінними що злочинці
доходять до того Що крадуть цілі дерева
оливковий фермер Мирон гілецакіс готовий
на все щоб захистити свою плантацію його
стратегія полягає у поєднанні нових
технологій та старих
методів Вони знають цю місцевість і
можуть
зорієнтуватися вони координують свої дії
по телефону ящо хтось хоче щось тут
вкрасти Вони одразу вимикають світло
Мирон гілецакіс патрулює оливкові дерева
на грецькому острові
Крит він тут аби захистити свої дерева
Від оливкових
крадіїв Вони приходять після опівночі
його прожектор може світити на 250
МТ якщо хтось захоче вкрасти оливки
сьогодні вночі і побачить прожектор і
машину Він швидше за все змінить свої
плани у середземномор'ї оливки - це
багатство багатьом деревам понад 100
років і ця олія невід'ємна складова
грецької
кухні і її крадуть у величезних
масштабах злодії відпилюють цілі гілки
або забирають уже вичавлену олію прямо
з-під носа у її
виробників цей кооператив найняв охорону
і встановив 37 камер
спостереження оливки дорожче за золотом
це серйозний виклик просто мати олію у
наших
резервуарах на плантації фермери
показують чому оливкова олія така цінна
зараз сезон збору врожаю Але дерева
дають мало
[оплески]
плодів якщо ви уважно придивитесь то
побачите Лише кілька оливок на
дереві Після того як я зірву ці
три-чотири оливки з цього боку на гілці
майже нічого не Залишиться тільки ці
чотири тут плодоносять лише ті дерева
які
зрошуються минуле літо у Греції було
дуже спекотним і сухим протягом досить
тривалого
часу це вже нова
[оплески]
норма ми знали про Кліматичні зміни але
не сприймали їх достатньо
серйозно тепер це глухий кут і ми
повинні якось вирішувати цю ситуацію у
нас будуть величезні проблеми з тим як
нам заробляти на
життя оливкова олія перетворюється на
предмет розкоші вона вже коштує на 30%
дорожче ніж роком
раніше підвищення цін зумовлене не
врожаєм в Іспанії найбільшому в Європі
виробнику оливкової олії через спекутне
літо високі технології можуть допомогти
ця оливка насправді
gps-передавач жоден злодій не зможе
відрізнити її від
справжньої
Ось вам приклад скажімо ми зрізали
кілька оливок GPS оливка падає разом з
іншими оливками і ви не можете їх
відрізнити Ось вона Бачите як важко її
знайти і вона водо непроникна я сам
перевіряв тож навіть якщо дощ буде йти
10 днів Це не вплине на її
роботу що хтось обдирає дерево GPS
передавач надсилає сигнал на телефон
Мирона щоб він міг відстежити
злодія бачите воно
рухається але мерон не може повністю
покладатися на GPS
оливки у період збору врожаю фермер
щовечора виїжджає на поля він не
перестає
хвилюватися
я ще можу виходити на патрулювання зараз
мені 46
років але коли мені буде 66 Я вже не
зможу проводити у полі цілий день і
патрулювати з ліхтариком всю ніч щоб
захистити свої
оливки
нелеокарпом єдине на що може сподіватися
Мирон що цього року буде більше
дощів логії допомагають нам усім
організувати наше життя оскільки вони
можуть взяти на себе повсякденні
завдання і цифровізація стає важливою і
у світі мертвих дозволяючи владі
відстежувати місце останнього спочинку
людей в Італії з'явився додаток який не
лише допомагає користувачам знаходити
могили своїх предків але й свідчить про
те що померлих шанують і не
забувають
а на цьому ми завершуємо наш
сьогоднішній випуск Щиро дякуємо вам за
те що були з нами сподіваємося вам
сподобалась наша програма і до зустрічі
наступного
[музика]
разу